over the years they get jaded they don't
think that it's going to happen to them
but that's when things turns divorce
when you don't think it's going to
happen to you and I've seen it too many
times so what do you think of like those
fat cops that look at you and go hey me
and you the same guy
[Music]
welcome back to the third installment of
this careful Boys episode featuring
trong when hey thank you guys we um if
you guys have been following along the
first two we are now getting to the
point where uh Trung enters SWAT Chicago
SWAT what was it like to get into that
it was another selection too uh you
couldn't try out until you did three
years as a police officer so you have to
do mandatory three years they didn't
even count your time in a L.A [__] they
don't care they're like so that's La
policing we do Chicago policing
different yep is it because it's like
every state has different laws so you
have to learn the stuff from each state
you know honestly when you get into that
level of like trying out for SWAT I I
really think like if you are prior
military and stuff like all that should
be waived because you kind of already
have like a kind of understanding of
what is needed for that type of small
unit yeah you know environment but
Chicago being the Chicago way they
wouldn't wave it they don't give a [__]
I know there's certain departments that
would it they find out that your prior
service especially if your prior Special
Operations they'll waive that time frame
you're like yeah let's get this guy in
Illinois State Police does that uh and
they and their whole training regimen
was made from a Delta Force guy so they
they hired a Delta Force guy to come in
to oversee their Pipeline and that's one
of their their requirements like hey if
your prior to Special Operations we're
waving your [__] uh Highway time you
can [__] try out six months yeah it's
almost like a waste of time just yeah
push more incentive for them because
they want the better guys in doing those
jobs yeah yeah I I couldn't join until
year five because when I joined at that
time they were testing every three years
so by the time they test around I was
only I only had two years in right damn
so I literally have to wait an extra
[__] three years so year five into
Chicago was when I was able to get my
shot at it what was their selection like
uh you know their selection was
was like a TV show or the movie yeah
yeah you know they got a swim swim test
they got a heightened heightened
confinement test and you know they got a
rifle school they had an obstacle course
they got a uh you got to do two pull-ups
with a 25 pound vast stuff like that
like their own little selection in there
dude yeah our class at the time when
they open it up again
there was about a hundred
seventy five cops and out of there we
got they got like 12 12 of us
the others just didn't make it yeah they
felt that either the pistol test they
felt either rifle school they either
failed the swim test you know they we
start losing people but the most of the
time that we lost was during the tactic
phase like when you start entering like
and how to take a room how to do all
that stuff what do they do Friendly Fire
stuff yeah so stand right there under
such a face what's the well yeah what is
the common weight of like that you saw
people failing the tactics
um they were not processing the room
correctly because under stress and under
chaos
it's either you can think through it or
you can't some people lock up they they
they don't do their movement correctly
they don't hit their points of
domination and if you guys know what
points of domination is is if you're
entering a room you want to build an
L-shaped fighting position
towards an enemy so if this was the bad
guy that we're going after and this
l-shape has been used all the way back
since Alexander the Great that's how he
conquered so many [__] countries was
he'll push his initial troops head on
then he'll have another additional
troops come and Molly [__] them from the
side so you know how it's like that
whole L-shaped Ambush so from that
tactic alone he was able to conquer
pretty much all of [__] Asia back
then like that you know so it's still
used to this day and how that works so
well is our mind we're not John Wick
like the movie right you're not able to
process multiple people at once and be
like
tell me that's fake oh my God it's it's
so real so what do you want what do you
watch the movies like I know it's like
fun as entertainment but do you like
just go like oh my god dude yeah a lot
of it's like you know just for like you
know entertainment purposes yeah you
never shot someone like this yeah I shot
someone like this oh wow oh [__] that's
a dance
right between the Boston
yes
no but yeah so for example let's say if
I enter this room which oh Colleen if
somebody enters this room your first
initial process is to to track him or
her correct yeah that's gonna be your
focus your focus and the other person is
going to go the opposite side so now you
have to pick one oh okay I mean you
can't be like
Boom at the same time you know you're
gonna yeah you have to is that called
flanking I thought flanking from the
back yeah flank is from the from the
side or from the back right okay this is
more like hey overloading their sensory
uh overloading their ooda Loop because
you're having multiple people enter the
room one side the other side so they're
like what the [__] it's like whack them
off so yeah so you have to process right
and that's and that's the thing that
people don't understand how do you win a
gunfight the person who who can out
process the other person wow is who's
going to be the one who wins so how does
that work I see you my brain recognize
you as a threat I pull my gun out I
shoot that is the whole processing
system now if I can out process you by
the time you want to shoot me my buddy
already shot you because by the time I
decided who I wanted to shoot it's too
late it's too [__] late do regular
cops also do that when they're trying to
like apprehend like a crazy guy that's
like it really depends on the police
department on their training level some
are better trained than others but they
would try to build an L shape or they
will try to build something called a uh
V you know what I mean so it'll be like
the dudes here I'm here you're here so
now we're talking to this individual now
he has to concentrate on one of us and
if he's like resisting arrest or he
doesn't want to go to [__] jail one
of us got to be the less lethal officer
right get the taser ready get the mace
ready so this guy's talking to him hey
put your hand behind your back so he's
occupying him he's like no I'm going to
[__] jail and he starts to approach
my partner with bald fist that falls
under the the law of my news of force
then I can use my Taser and taser and
whatnot so how is it uh once you finally
get selected first one what's the first
thing they do like not like hey you're
in you're a new [__] guy again
oh yeah you're a [__] new guy you
carry the breaching equipment you're
doing all the [__] work you're getting
the Bearcat ready you're doing all that
you know learning learning the ropes
driving the Bearcat that's the first
thing you do as a a SWAT dude you think
like oh I made SWAT I get to kick
indoors no you're driving the
[__] barricade is the Bearcat
the big vehicle that's like armored yep
and the reason why is like they want you
to learn the streets they want you to
see how their team does the hit on the
house
so the the getting the Bearcat to the
right house is very important do you
stay in the car you have to stay in the
car you have to stay in the Bearcat
you're the [__] new guy hey move the
Bearcat up a little bit because there's
a guy up there with the with a rifle
right I get him give me that position
move it up a little bit turn the
spotlight towards these windows you know
and stuff like that so with with your
experience as Special Operations when
you got to the SWAT team where would you
say your Tactical expertise was is it
closer to the top or in like in the
middle was like everyone's special ops
in there no a lot of guys were just
regular guys regular cops regular
civilians that worked their way up yeah
work their way up so you don't have to
be prior military to join the SWAT team
you just got to have that mindset and be
able to process and think under stress
if you're able to do all that then you
have a good chance of making the team so
even you as a special ops vet they
didn't give you any special treatment at
all they weren't like wow yeah they were
fanboying like yeah
I was getting uh [__] talked on more
because you know at that time I had my
Instagram page and they're like oh this
guy coming in blah blah you know it's
Instagram page blah blah blah blah blah
you know just you know there's clicks
inside trust me it's not what you think
it is it's not thinking uh 65 guys on
the SWAT team everybody's [__]
brother love each other no it's none of
that [__] there's Clicks in there too
there's people who stick together people
will talk [__] there's it's like that
man and I just gotta
shut the [__] up my first couple years I
I came in there I act like a [__] new
guy I didn't come in there with any chip
even though I trained constantly for
that five years going to outside schools
on my own dime to keep my skills sharp
damn and I and it shows like and I tell
people if you want something no matter
what profession it is
if you practice you learn you keep that
skill set and by the time you get there
you'll crush it and I and I crush the
whole [__] thing because I prepared
nice you know what I mean there's
there's people who didn't prepare who
just showed up the next day oh yeah I'm
gonna try for swine they [__] fail
right away yeah what do you think you
know what I mean like you gotta prepare
man the test shouldn't be your practice
and probably early on there's like
there's like almost uh like a stigma for
social media in like a very high
testosterone place because I was in the
reserves when I was first doing our JK
stuff yeah and everyone's like what the
[__]
the whole time
yeah it's like what is this the f word
doing on social media all the time
yeah yeah that's so true yeah that's
very true I mean I think police
departments they miss an opportunity
with like you know certain individuals
if they if you're representing the
police force in a positive light you're
actually a better recruiter than the
actual [__] recruiters same
thing for the Army like there are so
many people DM me like hey man thanks to
you I joined the military you know what
I mean I
we are we are the recruiters for the
[__] recruiters because they see what
you did like oh my God they're
explaining to you yeah they're like Bart
was a [__] he was in the Marines he
did this look who he's doing a bear hat
now
look at this gay guy he did it
was there anything like coming from your
background of special ops was there any
missions that you went on as SWAT that
you even you were like whoa that was
pretty crazy it's just different rules
of engagement you know like in in the
military it was it was a lot different
than here here it's like now you're in
the end you aren't swapping you're still
a cop
you know I mean you're you're a cop you
have to follow the literal law you have
to follow the use of force continuum I
can't just go in there and just because
somebody has a knife in there like 10
feet away from me I can't just shoot him
in the face though you know overseas is
different yeah yeah you know what I mean
so yeah dude yeah I mean dude I remember
one Squad call
we came we had a long night last night
we went out and um my sergeant was like
man
I'm [__] tired let's comb in here do
some PT we'll hang out in the [__]
office and when the next crew comes in
we'll get the [__] out here a SWAT it
was like zero five in the morning a SWAT
job kicked off about this crazy lady uh
her son just recently got shot
right and he died and she just went bat
[__] oh so dude she went she stripped
butt naked she had a pickaxe a little
little [__] pickaxe right and so we
rolled on scene I'm like looking at this
lady through her window she's there butt
naked with this [__] pickaxe and
really I'm like
God damn it what's the protocol Yeah man
so we try to talk her out of it man you
know we understand what's going on you
know try to do all this talk back for it
went on for hours it got to a point
where the talking doesn't work anymore
yeah and she got like you know she's
like [__] this [__] I'm gonna [__] go
downstairs I'm gonna blow this [__]
house up so you know she turned on the
[__] gas and [__] like that we're
like [__] we got to go in now so we made
we made entry and she went down to the
[__] basement and dude this house was
the most disgusting [__] house I've
ever been in uh she threw dog [__]
because she let her dog [__] in the
basement for God knows how long because
she was lobbing dog [__] up at us I mean
not not just one lob of dog [__] I'm
talking about like continuous
unlimited ammo
so dude we we [__] told the tag team
to come in there hey here's a [__]
Shield block her I'm gonna go out I'm
gonna go in the back yeah so that's what
I did so she was distracted lobbing [__]
at this [__] dude right and I went
through I snuck through the [__] back
and I had a taser I said hey I had my I
had my button give me your [__] taser
because the back door was open we
reached the back door wow so I crept
through the back door and I opened the
back door and then she at that time she
I saw her last dog [__] that she grabbed
the [__] uh pickaxe and she started
whacking the [__] furnace right I'm
like oh my God I'm gonna have to tase
this lady right now
so I snucked in I had the perfect
[__] shot the [__] two lasers one
was at her titty and one was at her uh
[__] ribs I was like dude she's gonna
go down I shot it it went Jesus she
looked at it she went she ripped it off
I was like I was like oh my God not
enough batteries I was like didn't
here's the thing people think was she
high on the adrenaline that's adrenaline
adrenaline and some people are not
affected by tasers because you guys
gotta understand that tasers don't work
100 of the time they probably work like
40 of the time right really yeah same
thing with mace there's guys there's
people there were people in my Academy
class when we have to get mace right
yeah some of them took it like nothing
like like oh yeah right now they're like
me dude I was dying my eyes are small I
gotta even [__] smaller I love oh my
god dude it burned the [__] out of me
same well come to this story I taste it
our taser that we have was uh we had two
cartridges it was it was a newer model
because the older one only had one so I
shot her the first time I thought I was
like dude she's gonna [__] fall it's
gonna be awesome I'm gonna come in and
cover I shot her she didn't go down I
was like oh my God so I was like [__] so
I I get ready to shoot her again and
here comes my buddy with the [__]
Shield he smashes her against the wall
she's trying to pull off his [__]
helmet right then um she somehow finagle
her way out of the [__] Shield I
shatter her again this time on her other
titty but it hit her this on this side
yeah this time it incapacitator longer
enough for us to come and put cuffs on
her yeah but but the whole [__] time
there's dog [__] all over the floor
she's trying to [__] bite me I was
like oh my God this is this is insane it
was it's different man being on suise
like you think it's just you're going
after drug dealers uh cartel no man a
lot of time you're dealing with [__]
crazy crazy mentals and that's what most
of the time you were dealing with wasn't
that people with mental illness and we
would just have to sit out there for
hours we'll lock down the building we'll
sit out there negotiator X come and talk
and they'll talk their ear off
of that in the you know that individual
hey you need to surrender hey surrender
you know you shouldn't do that so what's
your take on because now that I know
that what it seeing how hard it is
already for SWAT people to deal with
mental issues what's your take on people
that go no sentimental health
professional instead of cops
yeah it's kind of a dumb thing no
it happened once in uh this one District
that well it's the 24th district and
they sent this uh Aid workers social
social workers to talk to this lady then
she had two boiling pots to watch like
the [__] out I'm gonna blow this I'm
gonna [__] pour this [__] on them
they're like call swad call the cop
yeah that's exactly what I imagined
every time oh like you're not prepared
for that bro and it's different and we
we can't just go in there and just kick
in the door and as much as we love to
just to you know end this we can't you
know yeah I that call right there we sat
out there for 16 hours dude wow overtime
baby
[Laughter]
bro I'm ready to go home go home bro
this is like I'm exhausted did you get
lunch break yeah you got lunch break
so answer so on on the teams they
they'll buy like a bag of [__] uh
cheeseburgers from McDonald's okay so
that's what we eat that's pretty cool
you guys take turns yeah take turns so
it sucks
are you still with the department now or
no so now he has his own brand we go
home and so maybe you could talk a
little bit about about that and what
it's about yeah so I started we go home
when I joined I joined the military
um really happened during my first
appointment overseas uh I realized like
hey man you know when you train with
your guys from your left and right every
single day you bleed with them you know
you laugh with them you know you you go
through all the the [__] with them
and you're overseas it's we didn't we
didn't care about what was going on back
home in terms of like the politician the
politics the government we I the only
thing I gave a [__] about was my
brothers to my left and right to make
sure that they get home to their friends
and family because that's who I I met
back back then when we were over the
Stateside you know we got I got to meet
their kids I got to meet their wives we
hung out we barbecued we became a family
yeah so we go home really start from
there and it branched it it branched out
to the milk from the military to my time
in the police department you know uh
hanging out with my partner in my squad
car I got to meet his or her family you
know and it got to the point where it's
just like hey it's not about me it's
about those whom I left and right and
I'm gonna do everything in my power and
that's the message we're trying to push
to the people who are in the fire
department in the police force in the
military that hey when you raise your
right hand you're signing a blank check
right you don't know when it's not your
typical nine to five where you just
clock in go to work you might get
bitched at by your boss but at least you
know you could get home at the end of
the day when you do this type of job the
day you the day that you walk out you
might not come back and I've seen it
happen so many times and I'll show you
one last story because it's so [__]
true so that's what we go home is based
on you have to be physically fit
mentally sharp and and hone your skill
set because it's not about you it's
about those here left and right you got
to bring your brothers and sisters home
and the citizens that you swore to
protect
so we so we started this movement so
that we can get these uh police officers
that don't train often you get them back
into the mindset hey your uniform is not
enough
it might be enough for us people who
obey you but when you go against
somebody who doesn't obey you what's
going to happen if you don't take Jiu
Jitsu if you don't do PT if you eat like
a piece of [__] now you're fighting for
your life I bet you're that moment right
there you wish you had some kind of
training right that goes back to the
foundation of preparation yes and being
in that moment and I'll show you my last
story on SWAT that was really effective
uh we had an active shooter that
happened at the Mercy Hospital in in
Chicago so there was a doctor working
that ER she got into a domestic with her
uh fiancee she wanted to break up with
him so he's like okay let's break up
meet me out in in the front give me back
my ring so he called her she came out
from the ER she you know wherever they
had a discussion she gave back her ring
and he pulled out a pistol he killed it
right there he smoked her then he
[__] showing the camera he stood in
front of her body then Cops car started
coming he started shooting at the cops
car
then he ran inside the hospital and he
shot these two uh I don't know if their
nurse or they worked I know they worked
there they were just getting out of the
elevator and he shot one of them dead
and he shot then he turned the gun
there's a there was an officer there
there named officer Jimenez he only had
like a couple years on the job he was
either dropping off a prisoner or doing
some kind of uh paperwork for the
district that you work in District is
divisions or you know whatever Police
Department
you're in you're at and he hurt the
gunfire
so him and you know our team started
responding to that [__] call and they
were following the trail of the gunfire
and they got to a point where it was
like a T intersection so it's like a t
like so it's a hallway that leads to
another hallway and that shooter was
behind uh on the opposite side and one
of my team members he was a sniper and
officer of men as bound across to to the
next cover and cover is a place as a
cover it means uh if this if this wall
is concrete that's covered that means
that rounds can't hit it so they're
bounding to the next area of cover and
as they were bounding one of the rounds
that dude stuck the gun around and shot
and one of the rounds hit officer
Jimenez riding a juggler and he bled and
died that at that very moment in the
hospital
and I guarantee you when he woke up that
morning before he put on a uniform the
last thing he thought it was he's going
to die in that hospital or in in the
hospital especially so doing paperwork
in the hospital like you don't think you
know yeah you never know yeah so
and then so like we go home is to
encourage and it's a fitness program and
then like a like a nutrition division
yeah yeah so we do all that Fitness we
sell apparel and stuff like that I see
uh we're just trying to push the message
for the community to stay sharp to to be
better
than you were yesterday because it's
you're it's not you can't be selfish
once you raise your right hand it's no
longer you it's about everybody else
you're you're now called for a higher
purpose you better live up you better
live up to that
and that's what our message is about
live up to that oath that you swore
be be that person when you raise your
right hand when your Bright Eyes bushy
rookie recruit whatever you were
remember that don't lose that because a
lot of people lose that yeah over the
years they get jaded they don't think
that it's going to happen in them but
that's when things turns to worse when
you don't think it's going to happen to
you and I've seen this too many times so
what do you think of like those fat cops
that look at you and go hey me and you
the same guys
hahaha
yeah
it's disheartening you know is it is it
because after like Boot Camp or whatever
for like the academy you don't have to
do a physical fitness test so they can
get big or because yeah I always
wondered that when there was a when
there's like there's so many videos
where they can't keep up when they're
chasing somebody or yeah falling and but
then you have to do like some sort of
like renewal process yeah there should
be a standard yeah in in the Chicago
Police Department you get paid 350 to
take a a physical fitness test every
year and it's like 20 minutes of your
life
oh you know uh bench press 95 for men
bench press 95 of your weight and they
have a [__] machine it's not even
[__] free weights wow
touch your [__] you know the toe tone
reach thing do do 40 sit-ups and run a
mile and a half sounds like bare minimum
High School like PE class
yeah the standards is not that high in
the police department and that's a damn
shame especially for what's going on out
there absolutely I want the best [__]
cops to show up when I call 9-1-1 yeah
oh yeah you know I don't want some fat
[__] who just finished eating from
goddamn uh Burger King or something show
up to my [__] odd sloppy uniform all
[__] up because there was many of them
in the Chicago Police Department
unfortunately yeah there's many of them
here yeah we got lots of those I mean
even worse yeah way worse a bunch of
guys shaved head sorry Nick not you but
I mean
no just a bunch of LAPD dudes like they
don't know what they're doing half the
time like all the videos
it's it's it's hard now man I'll be
honest like now being being a police
officer is
a lot harder than it was a decade it's a
different game it's a different ball
field no one wants to be a cop anymore
yeah they're hurting so bad for police
officers everywhere because you know of
they don't want to be the next YouTube
sensation they don't want to get suede
they don't want to be called racist they
don't want to be called this and that
you know because they're kind of like
counterproductive though because now
you're lowering Enders just to get
people
oh 100 lower understands like Chicago
now doing the complete opposite of
actually having the proper people in the
positions that are supposed to uphold
they're scraping the barrel now they're
they're they're starting like they're
starting to see because here's the thing
if I'm intelligent and I'm physically
fit and I see what the [__] going on
in the police department where I'm like
I'm joining the three-letter agency
because you never see anything about FBI
CIA you don't see them under the
microscope right you only see police
departments they're like ah no
big brother right because the Epic if
the cops do something bad the FBI comes
and investigates who investigates the
FBI
so yeah guys check out
um you'll find trunk socials in the in
the info below and when you're on his IG
you can also link over to uh we go home
all the different accounts on there and
thank you for joining us
[Applause]
I have a holy fans no I'm just like I
don't
foreign